you and summer walker on a record
together that's that's a big feature man
like
like she must have been really she must
have really [ __ ] with your [ __ ] like
how did that happen
um honestly it had happened because i
was on tour with her
you know when it came time oh by the way
does london on the beat know that you're
that you're notorious for uh but well
well see that's the thing
because it's it's it's a respect okay
okay for sure as long as you respect her
boyfriend you ain't gonna yeah
respect me we cook up all right yeah no
he's great
for the show it's a respect thing i
never i mean anyway i'm sorry to
detract what you were saying continue to
don't look at me like that either so
it's not
anything but yeah though you know we um
i was on tour with her um we had
we like she had she she liked my music
she was [ __ ] with me
um had game time for a remix i'm like yo
[ __ ] if someone don't get out there i
don't want nobody else on it like
they had to make it happen because if
they make it happen i was gonna find a
way to make it happen
that's facts like real talk i won't lie
i might be one of the only artists like
besides like maybe like young boy that's
like signed to a label
that like still do what they want like
real talk like i do what i want like
and my my label you know
they they would it that's why i [ __ ]
with capital so much because
[ __ ] like i ain't pointing them in the
wrong direction yet like i haven't did
nothing wrong yet so like i mean
maybe they'd be cool